contact
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Dead Space
we are here now's our chance yeah now's
our chance
battery oh
come on
why can't you do it
oh okay I understand it's an engineer's
job yes of course yes yes yes
[Applause]
very cool just gotta go over here real
quick don't worry Nicole I'll be right
there
a tectonic load
we don't have long before All That Rock
Falls
oh were you talking I'm hearing you
huh what I'm hearing you
yep what are you talking to me say it
again I missed it what'd you say
um
all right anyway goodbye
where what are we wearing
hold on I gotta stop in here some cool
Colony stuff very important engineering
business you wouldn't understand Nicole
you'll help from the control room you
say
God damn I'm strong
wow
all right sure
um
well uh something happened down here
not familiar to me so I have no idea
what this is
what's going on here well dead bodies
I'm horrified
I'm terrified I'm awful fight
store power to the shuttle ah give me a
moment hey hey
no you don't you don't do that you don't
do that either hold still
I just got it here we go I just slice
your legs up hold on
hold on
there you go
foreign
plus Dace is here which is very useful
very handy very cool
oh wait a minute were you just busy at
working here oh wait wait wait wait wait
hold on oh that's good
douche
huh
on the market though
the eye of the storm
they can't stand it too long I've seen
him is this pedestal weather it
Amplified
Demarcus pulse will be felt across the
planet
Dental sleeps and the living will see
what can't huh
interesting okay
um retrieve victims of Union Square
masks suicide from ages seven bodies are
to be transported to ishimura great
good yeah I know it's casket duty but I
think you'll like this one I hear a
buddy of yours is down in Egypt seven
and a kitty assignment like this should
leave time for a meet up don't scare the
rookie
whatever that means
not 100 sure what that's about
[Music]
oh oh
but I don't even want to get rid of Pang
bang seems cool
how would I get rid of pain I don't know
why I have a bang but I feel like I
shouldn't sell that maybe I should but
you know how I am I'm weird about these
things
it stays and that's that
living quarters you say why can't I go
there
why can't I go there fine
there's a bench here not that I need any
more upgrades uh god
um oh man
um
oh capacity girl
I still didn't get that upgrade but it's
fine yeah I didn't get this last upgrade
but it's fine
it's fine
it's fine it is fun it's totally fine
I'm not sad about it I'm happy I
probably just saved didn't I I just like
saving so much
let's do
it hello hey wait a minute are you
trying to sneak up on me okay go in
what hey don't do that
this weapon is the best
well the plasma cutter is good
this weapon's decent it's all right
hard to say what's best and what's not
best
hello ah
I like the sound of a Supply Depot that
does sound nice
good thing I don't have to move that
myself
well I guess I could buy ammo wait I
probably should have done that I didn't
buy anything because I constantly think
that I'm okay on ammo but in reality I'm
not the best on ammo
one moment
this wasn't open before was it oh
this is Sergeant Brown Newman hey second
evacuation report
the shuttle's gone took off and then
crashed right back down into the bay
took a whole crowd with it must be a
hundred people dead we bought the rest
of the shuttles God help us there's no
way out
anyone hearing this
do not land I repeat that do not land on
Egypt seven
okay that's a little hostile you don't
know that they could have been
dealing with their own problems maybe
you can't jump to conclusions like this
it's just it's rude
so rude to think in such harsh harsh
terms
mayhaps
in we go
back onto the Glorious pedestal
see I just don't know what works and
what doesn't work
I just assume that I'm being tricked the
entire time and everything is bad and no
matter what the only right solution is
to shoot things till they don't move
anymore
it's the only thing I can think of
fun
good that's
used all right
okay
that was kind of obvious
who's that who who there who there wait
no
who that hold on
take this
oh I love the freaking plasma cutter so
much stop it
I'm gonna squash you
that's what you get hey oh you hit me
after all that
you hit me you got me squashed
squash squash squash squash squash oh my
God hello
where'd you come from
who is hitting me oh you're still alive
I squashed the crap out of you
these guys think these guys keep
thinking
[Music]
and your parents
your mother was unitologist
is this what she would have won is she
dead
would that make this easier maybe it's a
good thing I'll never know
maybe it is a good thing I don't know
much of anything that's the one thing I
do know is that I don't know anything at
all and that gets me through life pretty
confidently
I always feel good about the fact that I
know what I don't know and I don't know
what I don't know
but I know that at least not
that's nice
where am I go here
there where everywhere
uh wait that goes to holding Zone next
one
that's a toolbox but I want to go over
there
how do I get in there transfer Junction
I like transferring oh there is a
special place over here so this is
different
hello
ah good
good good
oh my God
oh that's handy for me
hold on marker I'll be right there
save point huh convenient
I do like saving how many saves that 85
saves I've saved 85 times
85. I think there's no power in the
section
time it's okay hit test connection
what's it say power failure detected
tether generator
I'm on it
ah it's gonna get me
contact
that's gonna get me
miss me hey how are you still alive
hey wait what oh
well that was handled now what
ah that way but that means I need to go
excuse me I'm so sorry I need to go not
that way
there's so much stasis here I appreci I
apprec so hard
this is delightful how much stasis is
here
you wouldn't have to shoot a goddamn
thing
oh and so much credit
I love credits hey wait a minute what
what's this doing here
three nodes
I could probably use one of my other
weapons that I've never used
I'll probably be able to fully upgrade
it in one splash I mean it wouldn't be
kind of cool I guess
all right restore power
what oh god
[Music]
probably fine probably not acids that's
gonna eat through my soup
probably oh this looks important uh
sure tether is in the thing that's
holding up the giant piece of rock over
our heads that's gonna come Crashing
Down
that tether that's um
that doesn't seem too good
well that that battery's working
um
well I got one more
here
generator
well that was Andy Dandy
nice buy another one
oh ripped it right out of there
power restored to Central generator
okay so there's one more missing
where could it be
huh
there's something missing here oh are
you hiding one
you had one
one of you wasn't hiding one
that seems unlikely
oh maybe this one's not necessary
emergency elevator
well one of the odds is going to be an
emergency
zero if you ask me
[Applause]
cool
gravity
oh wait a minute power is slowing again
come back to the marker quickly
okie dokie then
I'll do exactly move that seems
dangerous
um
oh where am I going
oh I see
I saw another one I thought I saw
another one maybe I didn't
fall down there
hello who's Grumble oh oh god oh
hi everyone
I guess this had a lot of time to oh God
I could have just gone through that
yeah
yeah a lot of time to oh
good good
all right there it is there it is
wait a minute yeah yeah
what are you
cool I think I'm done there that's all I
needed go back through
mission accomplished
I did it babe
babe are you still doing twitch don't
you twitch on me
what do you dare to put on me hey wait a
minute you stop let's see who was over
there whoa what are you doing
hey
hey get on me
you freeze
you freeze freeze I said
what day big one oh my God I'm so not
fast right now but I'm Gonna Get You
okay oh
no do not do not do anything of what
you're doing holy [__]
oh my God I'm almost there I'm out of
Health oh my God I'm out of Health holy
crap you could kill me in a heartbeat
where are you this damn baby you better
die oh my God how strong is this baby
oh
aiming
well I don't think that could have gone
any worse
even eyes
oh yeah oh geez yeah yeah yeah I know I
also forgot that I could have stasis the
baby and I just stared down as it
speared me also I never got the large
med pack thing
oh whatever who needs it not this guy
not not this guy never this guy huh this
guy no way no way
all right
I push it up
I did that it was my fault for using
like the pulse rifle the pitiful gun why
did I ever choose this one I could have
had like the flamethrower as opposed to
this one
for some reason
this is what I chose
don't know why
can we uh for a long Mr marker we heard
it hurry it along
it's over here
I have not looted this side yet
just the bulbous sack but not an
exploding bulbasack you'd think that
eventually this uh hive mind type
Necromorph creatures would uh evolve to
not have bulbous exploding
bulbous exploding sacks
not suspicious
not suspicious in the least
oh whoa
I thought that was an explodey
oh what is hanging in the middle what oh
it's a crane I thought it was something
terrifying
love lockers
what
go
crazy enough
thank you thank you
oh over there
wait there's something blocking it here
where is the bulbous
where's the bolbo this did blow up this
way uh up here
right I'm sure all this writing says
something really delightful that
everyone would want to know
um
but I just never learned the language ew
I'm grown like that ever
what is that
laughs
uh-huh
can't see anything over here
just stop oh you're horrible
horrible
I know I don't need to kill him but I
just feel like it's important that I do
there it is
that's a bulbous sack If Ever I saw one
more up all right
oh boy
how can anything still be alive after
that let's go in the universe you dead
you dead you dead
probably
whoa
fun
huh
well that was a fun winding trip
up and down and around and over and now
it's all over
and I'm back here
simple
I don't even know there wasn't even a
bridge there what do you mean Bridge
control there was no Bridge
uh
okay I'm almost out of ammo that one
let's use the big boomy okay we must be
getting close to where we're supposed to
be going I can't I can't believe that
they would have built all this
specifically just to move this
I guess it's just general purpose like
all kinds of different uh
resources can be moved along nice boot
they are a mining Colony so I guess they
would need to build Trails of racks of
tracks tracks and trails and racks and
trails of some kind
I'm hurrying
going as fast as I can
what hey wait a minute
but you don't like that
okay okay
it's got to be a goofy
agushi goopy
has got to be a kasploy good bloopy
a slam bloody babluskey
scrambley to bloomy there it is this is
all right
contact
how are you still living
is there another one or would there be
another one this is impossible did that
clear a path or something that I didn't
see
hello
[Music]
oh big guy coming in contact
YouTube contact
oh what are you doing there don't do it
Wham
contact one more
I just got a funny feeling
laughs
another need to explode
yeah I did see something over there did
you just get blasted into the group over
there I thought I saw a pair of eyes
just looking right at me
Hey look it's against bloody I can
actually stomp on you get stomped
there we go
I'm trying I'm trying babe babe who did
that you contact
hey wait a minute
take this
and then you take this
is that an audio line what is that doing
there
text log okay sure I'll read
I've quarantined the former doctors
Clifton and Hogan were barricaded in I
intend to keep a complete log no matter
what happens out there different vectors
of infection seem to be someone needs to
keep a record if the marker signal can
change a body from a distance we need to
know the chest of Dr Clifton's corpses
started to expand like uh like it's
taking a deep breath something appears
to be happening under the surface of the
skin the body's convulsing there's a
yellowish Briny liquid it's bursting
from the mouth he's choking but he's oh
God I hope it's gas release okay now
there's uh the esophagus is bulging in
the Jaws collapsing the head his head is
splitting apart is reforming almost like
a proboscis with feelers chest is
splitting along the center now this
chest is splitting and it's stretching
it's expanding outwards as the uh
internal organs muscle and bone are bent
inwards can I get a scanner please no
the scanner thank you so the uh internal
organs have organized themselves it's
the structure isn't back there seems to
be a central organ now resembling a
massive bladder the bladder is filling
with liquids some of which can be seen
spilling from his the creatures
probuscus so the two must be connected
the legs are quivering violently the
flesh is peeling away and uh merging
with the Flesh of the chest [__] sorry
[__] the uh leg just bent backwards and
um okay now the other one just snapped
back at the knee as well and uh starting
to sit up oh that's uh it it seems fully
reanimated can we uh hello psac yeah
anyone who's free to euthanize God do I
have to think of everything oh the um
spatter on the glass is making
observation difficult I missed that Dr
Hogan is also transforming but it's not
the um his legs are elongating somehow
flaying themselves they're twisting with
a mixture of his own internal organs
into a single appendage sort of like a
tail his face is contorting his Jaws
clenching and unclenching it's
punching on itself and oh [__] several
uh jaw like appendages are emerging from
his mouth
but it it can't accommodate that oh well
there you go his head is splitting open
like Clifton's I
oh [__] he's circling the room it's not
like Clifton it's like he's hunting does
he see me no the vents he's going for
the vents PSEC pasek is anybody there
sounds of impacts screaming and an
organic crunching noise that could be
anything that doesn't mean anyone's in
in jarly or whatever it could be
anything you I'm gonna that's a head
that's a well hold on there we go let's
go join the hive mind down there
since that's what you really want hey
wait a minute hey wow
douche he's getting it exploded
all right finally I can open this bridge
I hate you with this I'm gonna hit you
with this
take this
hey
oh
guys are wimpy
come on
ah it's so funny these guys are
hilarious oh
thank you yeah now reunited with the
pedestal I will do that yes babe of
course babe you got it babe
reunite that's a nice pedestal
[Music]
thank you
I always believed in you
no
[Music]
[Applause]
evacuate immediately
I'll restart the tether by his time
go
go go go
that's a little rude you know babe
you mad at me hey babe babe
but I made his whole babe
all right habowski
uh oh forget it Isaac interesting
go Daniels let who go
you should know you are
oh I gave you a chance to come around
Isaac but if you still won't see it I'll
help you I'll help you one last time
Wrigley override this time watch to the
end
Isaac it's me
oh I wish I could talk to you
I'm sorry
about everything
I just wish I could talk to someone
falling apart here
I can't believe what's happening
strange
such a little thing
instead of talk
that's all this research was in the end
not much is it
just had to make it listen when he
begged for convergence
but I had a different
bespoke
you cannot listened
make this stop
I said
maybe it understood but
[Music]
I never knew it was taken
why can't I see you again Isaac
I loved you
I always loved you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Jacobs
no
she can't be what the hell did you do
you did this to yourself
Nicole's been dead this whole time you
just couldn't handle it could you
because if she's gone
at least now it'll be in safe hands
the marker won't turn anyone else into
its puppet
give me the load of remote
no
it's over we're whole again I think I'm
not going to ask again cross no I'm not
people have died then just do it
it's better this way Isaac
you'll never recover from what the
markers done to you
and when the tectonic wheel drops all
this will be buried just like Earth God
wanted
huh
hey I can't see
that's so weird that it's different
same end result but different like the
nuances are different and it's
specifically different but why
but uh Nicole is uh very dead
and now crosses too so functionally it's
it's still the same it's just
interesting oh I'm probably not good I
should probably skedaddle
[Music]
I'm giving myself my own objectives here
am I
foreign
[Music]
not good I'm gonna go with a big old no
goodie
very bad no goodie not at all good
oh
where am I wow this is a lot of goodies
this is goodies
it was not goodies and now it's goodies
wow this is some goodies
oh
all right that's all to it
oh good
this is excellent
um
I'm curious
I still got Bang
I just never used the other guns I don't
know why short range kinetic booster
device hydrazine torch firewall
laser trap oh that sounds cool
shoot a blade
I've never hang on I'm so I haven't ever
actually used this weapon I just want to
see no don't the storage I know this
seems super weird uh to do this like
this late in the game
um
I'm just curious you know I was curious
how does it work
[Music]
s
so I can just
that does seem very specifically useful
oh cool
I'm a sweet oh
[Music]
that's pretty cool I'm not gonna lie
that's that's pretty dope why have I
never done anything about that
oh man
what kind of can I ask
[__] this one season
[Music]
oh man
I just want to see what kind of upgrades
it could have
how badass can I make it ah yeah of
course
I have all
got a special one Ripper Blaze Edition
Ricochet additional Ricochet I do oh
just lots of ricochets I could tear
apart a whole room with those things oh
man yeah
that sounds so useful
ah man I got 13 no no I couldn't I
couldn't I shouldn't I mustn't I wasn't
oh no I could never could I even get a
one two three four five seven eight nine
ten eleven I could
pick it upgrade
no better time like the present to
unlock uh our truest potential
oh
then now we're here
oh man
I feel good about this
oh man I am just top tier gamer no one
can argue best gamer ever 100
gamer run
world record gamer abilities
um
ah Pang I'm gonna keep him paying unless
they
loses
foreign
this is part of the Arsenal and now it's
just part of it because you know you
ever you ever
done that I'm gonna die because I've
never used this weapon before and I'm
not gonna be good at it
hell yeah hell yeah give me some more
duration hell yeah ah yeah now that's
that's a weapon why pick this and not
the front frame thrower the flamethrower
I'll never know
the first one I came across and
therefore it's all I did
seems about right yeah I'll save after
I've done all these chicks
what was wrong with me I don't know
let's go do this
Nicole babe
oh
Flex warning Isaac I mean it
videos
Daniels
oh wow
[Music]
that's a lot of goodies
oh
all right
guys left oh frick guy what a badass
contact
contact stop moving stop no oh okay wait
hold on a second oh thanks for opening
the boxes for me contact
hold still contact there we go contact
hold still oh very still contact
ah that was that close
wait a minute that doesn't seem good
contact yeah oh [__] ow okay
hey wait a minute
okay hold on
attack ah come on
gotcha
such a [__] good shot contact don't
do it don't do it oh weird stop doing
that I don't like that
contact oh what what why no
contact
oh God damn you
just like I planned it
oh that was a hit
that's a lot of them come on
there we go that's contact right there
contact
I call this my can opener oh never mind
you open the cans
ah where'd you come from
foreign
what is that big growly
okay it was nothing exceptional
ow
oh wait the Ripper I got the Ripper Oh
no you're dead
hey Matt
hello
don't do it don't slam me you don't want
to do it don't do it
oh that looks important
foreign
as the power of the Ripper
oh don't do it
that's acid that's acid
all right get ready for the power of the
oh
come on
I think you're big and dumb and slow but
not another one
don't do it I'm going that way idiot oh
I'm going well here what do you do
yeah just flash your tits at me I guess
the power of that Ripper sucks it really
sucks I'll save it for close combat oh
[__]
I think I think uh maybe the the contact
was the right move for this particular
juncture of oh God don't do it oh that
was close
don't do it
[Music]
contact
no no contact there we go
today
I got hit by it again all part of my
plan oh
contact
oh that's getting closer
[Music]
okay well this gives me very little room
to work with I hope you know that
okay well this is okay I walked right
into that one that was my bed
you're really winding up for these it's
almost like you're mad at me
yeah why would you be though we're just
doing friendly friend stuff
contact nice tits
well that was hard to predict good thing
I was just running in a random Direction
yo the Flaming acid I feel is a little
unnecessary well you're doing that again
not even looking oh that one got me
oh contact
oh wait this is in contact hey whoa you
could have done this this whole time
good thing I've got the contact of a
lifetime okay I'm just gonna you know
I'm just gonna do it this way oh wow
yeah
gotcha
[Music]
well you're surprisingly easy to kill
huh
done killed it I win I'm the strongest
the strong I'm not going the right will
leave the planet yes poor Daniels
where's Daniel's body oh well it did oh
she's alive she survived it's probably
oh I'm really glad I upgraded that
Ripper
thank you
well I didn't do that
Isaac it's me
oh I wish I could talk to you
I'm sorry
I wish
an option to fast forward oh all right
so we have just finished the remake of
dead space one thing I'll say is I was
extremely authentic to the original it
made a few changes here and there but
they were almost all just convenience of
gameplay and like quality of life
changes that I think overall were an
improvement there were a few like uh
artistic things that I noticed and it's
like really weird that I noticed them
like the the hunter dying animation was
much better in the original than it was
here which is a fascinating thing
because I know it's like a very specific
animation thing to see it disintegrated
like I I maybe I'm tricking myself but I
feel like the disintegration to that was
a little higher quality and I think like
certain aspects of this remake didn't
have like that it's not polish see
polish isn't the thing it's an Artistic
Touch there's just that little bit of
artistry that occurs when you know
someone else's hand is making something
that is different in the other just like
that jump scare at the end I don't
really remember the jump scare uh from
Dead Space very well but I remembered it
was more impactful this one was okay it
was fine uh but I feel like the the
original just like something about it
was more unsettling than zombie and then
like Isaac has had Necromorphs lunging
at them it's it's more of the fact that
it's like in the mind it's like not
alone and having that little voice line
before it instead of just being pure
silence and then looking over if I'm
remembering it correctly I think was a
little better but it was great to go
back into the game it really was great
to be there again and see all of this
come to life again given that it's been
what 10 years since I played the last or
uh for the first time and it's just like
experiencing it all over again and I
love this game I love the way it plays
it's really really just a lovely lovely
experience there's something about the
environments of it the being and the
ship
um but one thing I'm like and I think a
lot of people might agree on is like I
don't know if Dead Space 2 needs a
remake because if you load up Dead Space
2 right now it still holds up it's
fantastic it still looks great it still
plays great and it's terrifying Dead
Space 2 is a very good sequel to Dead
Space Dead Space 3 was not and so I I
don't know where they're gonna go with
it from this moment on
um but I'm thinking that the tiny little
story changes and the characterization
changes are to expand it further into
the other sequels if they are rebooting
this whole universe I really like this
just because it's a good excuse to play
a game again
um whether or not it's your personal
decision to pay for a game that
essentially it is it is the same game
it's a remake but then again the
Resident Evil remakes I mean I love
those admittedly those are drawing from
way further sources where it's
PlayStation one and two level Graphics
so coming from this where the original
Dead Space still technically holds up
this is I I've got no problem with this
one I really don't especially and and
it's not just like I know some people
like oh there's nothing of value-added
there is something of value added in
terms of the franchise itself getting
new life if this means that dead space
as a franchise can continue and be
reborn I'm all about it and it seems
like the team that made this one is
really committed to an authentic Dead
Space experience so honestly like I'm
shocked that they managed to match the
feel of it at no point when I was
playing this did it feel not like dead
space and I think that's probably the
hardest thing to get because it's like
so it's so nuanced
um controls and what they do and how
they do it
wow
wow advanced soldier rig that's where
the other power nodes are
progressman saved you I'm like New Game
Plus
oh my God New Game Plus
hell yeah but no it's just like I really
like this this is fun I had a great time
I'll probably play it again try to do an
impossible challenge you know that's
that's what I did after I did the other
one I tried to do uh Dead Space 2 on
Impossible
um on a live stream but the game crashed
halfway through
so I lost everything New Game Plus oh oh
wow starting a new game plus will carry
over weapons items credits and upgrades
from your completed playthrough they
will be can be retrieved from the
storage of any computer you can expect
to face new enemies and prof's fine new
Mysteries to uncover
now of course you couldn't do impossible
because that's a very specific challenge
but I'm a
let me just
pop in oh it's got to do the whole intro
though
ah
there's only one reason that I really
did this is because there is a log here
that I did not get from the beginning of
the game and I missed it and I'm getting
it again
it is right here
this one baby
for your request here's what we can find
on the specialist Isaac Clark is born on
pool and Octavia clerk on two Powell
cool well in the Eastern Seabourn of the
region of the American Republic kill
kalark was an award-winning ship
architect employed by the galactic Union
Merchant Marine Corps his records show
extended time off world away from his
family when Isaac was born pure was
given a temporary reassignment to an
earth-based gump a ship production
facility during the four-year tour pure
and Octavia raised Isaac together when
the tour was over puel shipped off for
an extended off-world tour pure's
influence of it his son must have rubbed
off records indicate Isaac pursued
studies in mechanical and electrical
engineer in ajitai honors according to
medical and psychiatric reports pules
Clarks absence had a profound effect on
Octavia she suffered from depression and
personal anguish until doctors encourage
her to find fulfillment by working with
charitable organizations to believe that
as though she ended up coming into
contact with the church of uintology
after
really
really Soul cleanse
she sold off much of the family's state
to finance full membership and the Soul
cleanse great Isaac beers to have been
selected for prominent engineering
school but wishmazi was unable to afford
the tuition as record show he's attended
instead attended a lesser known school
with the help of scholarships and
financial assistance after graduating
enlisted a Merchant Marine quickly
gained a reputation resourcefulness two
years probably a higher profile Greer
stagnates at this point this would
coincide with psychiatric reports that
his mother's mental health they're
heading backwards showed payments ooh
seems to be a medical officer and
neuropsychiatrist called Nicole Brennan
name appears on Octavius physicist
instructor a few of them ended up
cohabitating until Brennan accepted the
promotion left to serve on the usgsimura
fuels returned from his extended tour
coincide with Octavius released from the
hospital whatever his assignment was
pure's service representative
classified by executive order and unless
he confide in Isaac he took a secret to
his grave the next records records we
have are the death notices for puel and
Octavia Isaac father was working on
something secret and classified you say
bodies will
Ed custody of Church Anthology along
with Clark's entire and State
octavia's wishes repeated petitions have
bodies return ignored great the cause of
death is unknown
more than qualified to handle job like
I'd talk politics over religion though
well there you have it
the mystery has been solved oh yeah have
you been calling me you waiting on me
well looks like I got my suit I don't
know what new Mysteries are available
but I probably played again actually
I'll probably do the impossible
challenge first so I don't know I don't
know about that impossible is um I think
just no deaths maybe like limited saves
actually I guess I could look
ah man three oh
no it's fine I think it's saved after I
restarted the thing but if you do uh if
you do a new game
you do there's impossible special
challenge completely with a unique suit
and a weapon this mode is the same
damage settings as hard difficulty but
Auto saves are disabled only one safe
slot is available and one life dying
prompts a full restart or continuing on
hard difficulty yeah so no dying how
many times did I die on medium a medium
was
can't tough so uh I don't know this
would be but anyway thank you everybody
so much for watching this was a very fun
experience I hope you enjoyed it
alongside me if you want to see Dead
Space 2 and 3 I'll provide links in the
description but those are older games
with younger me who God probably not
nearly as hilarious or quick-witted as
me but you know he gets along so go say
hi to old young me and uh have a lovely
day thank you and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye